look plenty of sounds are loud and scary
but there's a certain blood-curdling
quality to screams in particular it sets
them apart from other noises they can
elicit these visceral feelings that
pretty much everyone can relate to but
what exactly is it about screams that
evokes that response
screams are about survival a bear
stumbles into your campsite you scream
the baby gets hungry it screams some
idiot interrupts your shower you scream
there are some a staple of the horror
genre scary movies have been using
screams for decades to shock and
unsettle audiences it doesn't seem no
matter what movie it's in or even how
often they show up those screams get you
every single time why is that in 2015
researchers led by New York University
neuroscientist David Popple set out to
isolate what makes screams so unnerving
when the researchers compared the
acoustic properties of shrieks from
movies YouTube videos and volunteers
screamers to those of more neutral
sounds like human speech and music they
noticed something interesting to neutral
sounds fluctuated in volume between four
and five times per second but the
screens they wavered and loudness
between 30 and 150 times per second this
fluctuation happens too fast for you to
be able to discern a distinct rise and
fall in volume but it does lend the
noise a certain auditory roughness and
interestingly the researchers also heard
that roughness in house and car alarms
and here's what I mean by roughness
listen to these two tones
those were actually the same tone but
the second one was modified to increase
its roughness makes a pretty big
difference right the researchers also
performed fMRI brain scans of test
subjects while they listened to rough in
neutral sounds all of the sounds caused
blood to flow to the auditory cortex
which you would expect but rough sounds
like screams also caused blood to rush
to the amygdala a region of the brain
associated with processing fear and
danger we are too new that screams
sparrows what Koppel's findings help us
understand is why we find them scary
screams live in this acoustic region
that's completely isolated from other
forms of human communication and that
helps them capture our attention so
whether you're running for your life
from a crazed murderer or just enjoying
a good horror movie be sure to thank
auditory roughness and your amygdala for
that visceral human response to the
screen